the Joe Rogan experience when I was on
Rock season 5 of Fear Factor I remember
thinking I don't know how much longer I
can do this what was it about it that
was it was just too much repetitive it
was the same thing over and over again
we did 148 episodes right it was just
after a while it's just like Jesus
Christ how many animal dicks can you
serve people right how many times can
you throw him off builders yeah yes
enough stuff already
it was just there's no amount of money
to get you to come back to do that or
something like that did come back in
2011 I came back but I didn't I was I
didn't have as much money back then and
also it was a lot more money than I got
the first time it was like a big deal
because they were good I think it was I
don't I also don't remember about the
money part but it was a big deal it was
gonna come back but I immediately
regretted it look immediately I was like
oh my god I have a job again yeah I do
but I had I was just having children
then you know like yeah I want to take
yeah my kids were really young and I was
like I need like when you have a kid I
had an older daughter but I was already
paid for most of that then do you have
think about two children and you think
about two children that are like at the
time two and one you're like oh my god
like this is this is serious yeah I have
two may have 18 years yeah I have to
make a lot of and I think like all the
money I squirreled away from the
originals he's in a fear factor that
took care of my family for a long time
ago probably okay but I felt like this
overwhelming responsibility to squirrel
away more more money more money but then
once I started doing I was like oh my
god this is a mistake
yeah this is a mistake you like this is
crazy I'm like I don't like it yeah and
then we got canceled because we serve
people jizz who is that the final straw
yeah yeah they had a drink donkey calm
and that was it that was too much that
was that interesting as TMZ saved me
that was when you had the moral majority
back then and they would this was a
problem like that's when all the
censorship came primarily right from
like right-wing groups um sorta yes like
the Obama was do return okay but what it
was was the show had to get more and
more extreme and it was very dangerous
like it was freaking me out right
because they were taking a lot more
crazy risks like one of them you had to
you had a set of keys and you had your
partner was handcuffed to a tree and
they were attached to a bungee cord that
was attached to a [ __ ] helicopter
okay and the helicopter was had this
bungee cord taut and they're flying in
the sky above a giant Canyon I mean way
to [ __ ] up there right so you got these
keys and you're working these keys and
the idea is the first person to get the
key lock open right you unlock the thing
and then boom she's shooting into this
guy and I remember seeing them going
what if something snaps whether
something breaks yeah we watched someone
follow their death like what the [ __ ]
are we doing you know you just have a
bunch of executives going oh they just
make a face you know they would just go
yeah not great I had a joke about it
that they were gonna kill us all and
then guns down and blame it on the
terrorists all right don't let the
terrorists take away your fear back with
Mario Lopez you know it's just Joker
I was always joking around how Mario
Lopez gonna replace did you ever feel
weird morally about it because you have
these people that are coming in that are
putting themselves in these positions no
because I would have done it I would
have done it when I was broke I would
eat an animal dick oh yeah
throw puke in my face right there's
people that we know will do it now you
know buddy the works of the story yeah
we'll all do it now and a lot of us have
money and there was the idea that they
could do that and you know and moving on
to a career the only ones actually moved
it on to a real career was Michael yo
Michael yo it was on season 1 a fear
factor episode 1 EV someone's
interesting he's a crazy a comic you
guys comedians doing really was wild
just filmed a special he's a really good
guy that's great really funny he's
hilarious mine start on tier fact 100%
yeah 148 episodes three people per
episode yeah I remember I tested for a
reality show on Food Network and they
had me on set for about of an hour and
they were like yeah this is not I said I
said like three things into the camera
and they go none of this will ever this
is not going to work
[Applause]